Goemon so I could give this talk in
Danish but this is an international
conference so I'm I'm not gonna do that
there may be some people here who don't
understand anything that's fine I've
actually spotted one thanks for coming
so my name is Marc seaman if you want to
know more about me there's information
they aren't blocked upload a DK and you
can follow me on twitter on at play if
you're interested in hearing what I have
to say I mostly just tweet technical
stuff so and I'm I'm not that loud what
I'm gonna do here today is that I'm
going to try to answer a few frequently
asked questions and I'm gonna do this in
three parts so in the first part I'm
gonna start with one of these frequently
asked questions but then I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna answer the question I'm
only going to address why would you want
to ask that question and then in part
two I'll you know put the first question
aside and start talking about something
that seems completely unrelated but
turns out to be related and we'll take
that all the way through and then we'll
we'll use what we've learned in part two
and then in part three we'll go back to
the first frequently asked question
because now we have more information and
then we can start addressing that one as
well so it's a three parter that's the
plan so the first question that I'll try
to address here is how do I combine
dependency injection with a sink and a
weight without leaky abstractions that
is so that's the that's the requirement
here you know if you remove that
qualification it's not that hard but if
you want to avoid leaky abstraction it
becomes it becomes a little bit harder
so I'll start by just showing you a code
example of what is this that I mean so
we'll just take it slow and be sure that
everyone understands where this is going
so we'll start to look at some code and
whenever I show a code example I prefer
very much to reuse the same scenario so
I'm never you reusing the code but I'm
always reusing this scenario of having
to develop an online restaurant
reservation system if I can get away
with it and I can here so you know this
one of those systems where you want to
make a restaurant reservation so you
find a form
a website on app or something like that
and you fill in the date and all the
other information about the rest
reservation you want to make and you
press the submit button and that creates
a JSON document and that JSON document
gets posted to an HTTP endpoint
and the code that we gotta look at is
that HTTP endpoint so the server-side
code that receives that JSON document
and decides what to do next so we'll
start with the domain logic so in in the
domain logic what which will try to
decide is whether or not we can accept
the reservation so here's just the
method signature I'll fill it in with
some code in a little while but I want
to talk a little bit about the method
itself what it looks like
so the reservation is a DTO that's
basically just a Tartus transfer object
that contains the information from that
JSON document so the name the email
address the quantity and the date and
then you might wonder why does it return
a novel end well the end is a
reservation ID and that means if you
have a reservation ID that basically
means you have a reservation if you
don't have a reservation ID if it's null
then you don't have a reservation so why
might we not always get a reservation
well there might be various reasons for
that so let's let's look into how this
actually works now if we are doing
dependency injection we may have
injected a repository already so this
might be available the read-only
property or class field or something
like that so I'm not showing you how to
inject the dependency I'm assuming that
everyone knows how constructor injection
works in 2019 and it takes up space that
I don't have for the slides so that's
why I'm not showing you that but if we
have that repository dependency we can
go and start querying in that we can say
how many please give me the reservations
for that particular date and then we can
you know just calculate the sum of all
the quantities and that gives us the
number of already reserved seeds and if
we also know the capacity of the
restaurant we can make a business
decision and we can say well if we have
too little remaining capacity then we'll
have to reject the reservation attempt
here because we have sold out or pretty
much close to sold out but we don't have
enough remaining capacity for that
particular quantity so that means we
return null that means you don't get a
reservation
I D and that means you don't have a
reservation but otherwise we'll call
repository create and that you know
creates the repository create the
creates the reservation in the
repository and that also returns an
integer which is the reservation ID and
then that's what we return so you may
wonder where's the async and a wait here
and it's not I just want to establish
you know the normal dependency injection
code base first and then we'll look at
how to you know add some a sink and a
weight in a little while but we almost
done now if we're doing two main two
event design we might say well let's
extract this sort of behavior into an
abstraction so we might say let's define
an interface called the Maitre D' that
defines that try/except method so Maitre
D' is just a fancy word you know French
for hit waiter which is in many
restaurants is sort of like the person
or the role that makes decisions about
you know whether or not you can accept
reservations so that makes sense
and that also gave me the opportunity to
use the circumflex and Unicode
characters in code which is always
really a bother actually but it's fun
for slides at the boundary of the
application we may have some sort of you
know controller that accepts you know
incoming HTTP requests so how these
things normally work is that if you call
a method post it'll handle incoming HTTP
POST request so that's sort of what you
can imagine is happening here and we
return something called an action result
which is basically just an interface
that models HTTP responses so don't
worry too much about how that works it's
not really important but if we're doing
dependency injection we might say let's
inject that in Maitre D' object and that
means we can basically just delegate to
that object and say let's just you know
take that JSON document and delegate to
the maitre d we'll get a nullable ID
back and then we can test whether or not
it's null if it's null we'll return an
internal server error and otherwise
we'll return 200 okay so internal server
error here is just a helper method that
returns one of those action results in
this case and action result that
represents a 500 internal server error
HTTP response and the same thing goes
but okay okay is a helper method that
returns a 200 okay responds and you'll
notice in the 200 ok response here we
put the
reservation ID in the in the body of the
response so it's at this point we know
it's safe to go ID tar value we can get
the integer out of that nor blend so the
reservation repository looks like this
but then you go and you say well but
this is really a database you know our
implementation it's actually talking
through a database and that's out of
process so it really ought to be
asynchronous because that might improve
performance at least it's worth whether
try and see if we can make that change
and we can measure whether that gives us
a performance improvement that might
actually be a good idea to do but how do
we how do we make something like this
asynchronous well we you have to change
the return types these are normal return
types at the moment but you can change
them so that the return tasks instead
and then now it's asynchronous so it's
pretty straightforward except that this
is a leaky abstraction because you had
this interface and the reason we have
this interface was because the Maitre D'
objects required or needed that
particular behavior so if you're
following the dependency inversion
principle it is the client that gets to
decide what the interface is look like
and the client doesn't need this to be
asynchronous now you're letting an
implementation detail leak through into
the abstraction that is the definition
of a leaky abstraction so we don't even
have to debate whether or not this is a
leaky abstraction because / - finishin
it is but then you might say well but
doesn't really matter I could be pretty
pragmatic and I would probably say yeah
who are we actually kidding here we we
pretend that it's a repository but
really we should just you know own the
fact that it's really just a database so
okay fair enough that's it might not be
a big deal let's let's go with this and
see where it leads us because maybe it's
not that much of a problem
now if we make this change we can almost
or we can very easily fix the problem
here we can just you know add async and
await keywords you know strategic places
and that's basically gonna solve our
problem we also need to change the
return type to tasks there but apart
from that that's basically all we need
to do the only problem that we now have
remaining is that since we change the
return type of try/except
we now also have to go and revisit the
Maitre D'
interface and also change its return
type so at this point I'm getting a
little bit more annoyed with my leaky
abstraction because I could sort of live
with the fact that a repository
represents something that is almost
always an out of process resource okay
fair enough that needs to be
asynchronous but this is a piece of
domain logic or a piece of domain
decision a business decision that needs
to be made why does that need to be
asynchronous that's odd you know that
I'm sort of this you know this doesn't
sit well with me but there let's see
where where this goes
so am the final changes we need to make
is we just need to add async and await
keywords to the post method as well and
most modern web frameworks sort of know
that if you return a task they will run
things asynchronously for you so this
point the code compiles and it works and
it does what it's supposed to do so you
may say well is this a big deal there
are some leaky abstractions and then you
say well but it's just a few async and
await keywords and that's pretty much it
and I might be a client to agree I'm not
saying this is bad I'm just pointing out
that there is a trade-off here but what
I've told you so far is nothing new and
you've seen other people tell you this
old you know all the time you know if
you have to go async you have to go
anything all the way and the people will
often tell you there's no other way and
whenever people say that to me I'm
always like huh really because there is
another way and you know the only thing
I need to do to disprove the first
assertion there is just to come up with
one counter example and I can do that so
I can disprove that there there is
another way I can disprove that there is
no other way so just to be clear I'm not
saying what what I'm about to show you
for the rest of the talk is better I'm
just saying there's it's different way
of doing it and but I believe in choice
if you want to be you know as good as a
software developer as you can be it
helps to have you know options so
basically if you're not aware of the
option you can't make any decisions if
you're aware of options now you can make
decisions decision so so that's
basically where I am I believe sometimes
what I just showed you is fine sometimes
I would go with what I'm about to show
you next instead so it's not an either
a thing you can do well it is an
either-or thing but you don't have to
always choose one over the other all
right so this is part one of the talk of
we're done with part one of the talk so
I'm going to put aside this problem of
the you know asynchronous dependency
injection for a little while and I'm
gonna start talking about another
frequently asked question that at first
balance doesn't seem to be much related
to what we've been talking about so far
and that is how do I get the value out
of my monad now don't worry if you don't
know what a monad is we'll get to that
in a moment but basically the short
answer here is that it's new there is a
tradition in Zen Buddhist philosophy
that we use this response mu as meaning
unasked the question it basically sort
of means the question as it's currently
being asked doesn't really make any
sense and we should start unraveling why
are you asking this question and you
know why does it not make any sense
this happens a lot and it's there's
nothing wrong with asking you know a
it's not even a stupid question it's
sort of like a nonsensical question but
if you want a Western perspective on
this idea you can read zen and the art
of motorcycle maintenance so programmers
might want to read gödel Escher Bach
these are two Western perspectives that
talks about this concept of mu on asking
the question we see situations like this
a lot in when people are trying to learn
new things so if you're trying to learn
a new programming language or if you're
trying to learn a new software
development paradigm or just a new
library or stuff like that people will
often you know ask questions that don't
make any sense and we often call this
the XY problem Stack Overflow has a FAQ
that talks about you know what's the
expired problem but basically it's sort
of the same thing when you're trying to
learn something new you're always
struggling with me figuring out how how
does everything fit together and that's
not natural there's nothing wrong with
that at all but you can imagine that you
have some sort of goal that you'd like
to achieve and we'll call that goal Y
and you say this is what I need to do
and based on what you already know and
maybe based on some other paradigms that
you're already comfortable with you form
a plan for how can you actually
why and that plan may involve a series
of steps but then you stuck on one of
those steps and it's called that step X
and we say well I don't know how to do X
I can't figure out how to do X so you go
on Stack Overflow or somewhere else and
you say how do I do X and that is a
nonsensical question it turns out so
people will respond why do you want to
do X and sometimes people will do that
enough quite an aggressive tone and
that's not very you know comfortable but
sometimes people will just engage in in
sort of or try to engage in a dialogue
and if you do that you may be able to
communicate what was implicit that
you're not really trying to do X you're
actually trying to do y and once the
persons who are trying to help you
understand that they say oh in okay that
makes sense in that old you know style
of thinking that you're normally used to
but in this other thing that you're
trying to learn at the moment that
doesn't make any sense if you want to
achieve why you should do Z and that
will enable you to achieve the goal that
you wanted to achieve so we get that a
lot with in functional programming
people sort of ask questions that sort
of can be generalized to this one how do
you get the value of the motet this sort
of keeps coming up all the time so the
short answer is you don't but I should
probably tell you what a monad is
because I'm not assuming that you know
what a monad is already and it's one of
those words that have a lot of mysticism
and sort of people are a little bit
scared of it because it's sort of very
abstract but it's not really that hard
to to understand so I believe I can tell
you what a monad is in about 10-15
minutes and you should be able to
understand it it's not it's not harder
than that
so in short a monad is a function you
can flatten and then you go okay that's
not really about over here very helpful
because what's a functor so we have to
start with the functor and and talk
about what that is and then you know
once you understand that the monad is
part is actually pretty really easy to
understand so a functor is a container
it's not a docker container it's not a
dependency injection container it's not
even a shipping container it's just a
container of tartar so we might just
illustrate that with a little rectangle
here but you can think of this as a
data type in c-sharp this would be some
sort of data type and it would typically
be no not typically it will always be
generically typed so it would be
something like you know foo of T or bar
of T or something like that so it's just
a container of doubt of data of values
or of things like that and and in order
for a container of values to be a
function it must have one other quality
it must support what we call the
structure preserving map so basically
the idea is that you can take whatever
is inside the container and you can
translate the contents of the container
and the result will be a new container
that sort of looks like the original one
but with all the contents changed so
this seems quite abstract so let's put
some values in so the the example that
everyone understands that you've
probably done this a lot in c-sharp
already it's just a collection of things
so this might be you know a collection
of integers in this case or ienumerable
of something like that you know this is
one example of a functor so a structure
preserving map might be something like
where you say well let's add one to each
of of those numbers and now you get a
new container you get a new collection
of numbers but doesn't have to be you
know numbers two numbers you can go
numbers two strings or you can go
numbers two boolean values like this one
now the the last the third example here
also illustrates something else and that
is the structure is being preserved in
the sense that even though you think you
know boolean values it's just you know
false and true there's only two boolean
values why do we need to repeat them why
do we need to go false false false true
true false well that's because the
structure of the original input
container has been preserved and you
might find that redundant in this
particular case but that just means you
know there's always you know all of
these collections have six elements
because the original collection had six
elements and the order is determined by
the the order of the input so that's
basically what a structure preserving
map means when we are talking about
collections but to be clear this is just
one example of a functor and I'll show
you some other ones later on so it's not
a function it's not something that
implements an interface anything is just
an idea so another thing we might notice
is that the output of making that
structure
serving map is again one of our data
containers and that means we can use
that as an input for another step so we
can sort of chain these things together
and the way that it looks in c-sharp is
you could start with a collection of
numbers or an array in this case and
then you go dot select so select is what
we call the structure pessoa map in
c-sharp most other languages call it map
but for various reasons c-sharp course
it's selected so here we just take you
know each of the numbers and add one to
it and then we can do it again so we can
take each of those numbers and turn them
into strings and now we just have a an
array of strings so that's pretty
straightforward this is just how link
works and this has been available
available in c-sharp for more than 10
years so you probably know this already
but it's an example of a functor and
Microsoft the documentation doesn't
really tell you that this is a function
so it does a lot of very good the
documentation cut does a really good job
of telling you how this works but it
never really tells you that the
extraction this is based on is called a
functor so you may not realize that
you've been using functors and monads
for the last 10 years but actually you
have so if you look at this there you
might say well why would anyone ask the
question how to get the value out of my
monad because this one is a monad I
haven't talked about Monat yet but trust
me it is and it doesn't you know you
realize that it doesn't make any sense
to ask that question how do I get the
value out of my collection with which
value there's six of them all right here
there might be zero values how do I get
the value out of my empty collection it
doesn't make sense and people don't ask
that question so people so why do people
still ask the question about how do they
get value of the monad I believe the
reason is that you never really told
that this is a function you never really
told that this is a monad so I think
some people are a little bit unfortunate
or unlucky that whenever they encounter
the concept concept of a monad it's in a
different context and maybe they
encountered it in a context and like I
called unit containers so this is just
my you know homemade label they're a
unit container and the reason why I call
it that is because these are data
containers that are guaranteed to
exactly one one value so the example
that's been around the longest is
probably lazy of T so lazy of T is a
lazy computation and it's guaranteed to
contain a value of the type T you know
eventually when you force evaluation and
I'm sort of ignoring that it might throw
exceptions and stuff like that but if we
forget about that for a moment it's
guaranteed to contain a single value of
the type T just lazily compute your
computed so this is already a generic
data container is it a functor well it's
not you know it doesn't have a select
method in the base class library but you
can add one it's it's pretty
straightforward to add an extension
method that takes you know a lacy of T
and turns it into a lacy of T result all
you need is a function that takes T and
turns that into T result and the
implementation here's a one-liner now
I'm not gonna you know dwell too much on
the implementation of these things
because it's the concept I want to get
across so what you can do with something
like that is you can start by creating a
lacy int and even though this one has a
you know blocking it will block the
thread for ten seconds inside of it this
entire expression will it complete
immediately because it's a lazy
computation so it's a lazy of end it's
not gonna block until you actually force
evaluation and you probably know how
that works already now if I want to
transform my lazy end into a lacy of
string I can use that new selects
extension method that I just added
and that also completes immediately so
basically it's just it just does what
you'd like it to do it behaves in an
intuitively reasonable manner and that's
basically what we mean when we say it
preserves the structure of the container
it's just it it preserves the invariance
its it'll stay working the way you'd
expect the lazy of string to work and
it's only when you force evaluation that
it'll block for 10 seconds so again it
works just like you'd expect a lazy of
string to work and if you force
evaluation again it completes
immediately because now it's remembered
the result from before so doing that
transformation that you know calling
that select method doesn't change
anything about what it means to be a
lazy computation so that is why we say
it preserves the invariance of the
original container
so all it takes is just you know adding
a select method like an extension method
like this and you can do this with LaCie
of T you can do it with tasks of T as
well and you notice the implementation
code is a little bit different but not
much and now we can basically walk
through the same sort of example again
where you can say we will start by
having a task of int and that entire
expression completes immediately now
it's going to start that task on a
background thread it's it's gonna start
running but you'll get your task of Ind
immediately and again you can call extra
selects to turn the task of IND into a
task of string and that again just
completes immediately it it's only when
you await the string inside the task
that you will actually have some
blocking behavior because that task is
probably not finished running by that
time and again if you do it again it'll
complete immediately so again this just
preserves the invariance of what it
means to be an asynchronous task so
everything you'd expect a task of string
to all the rules that you expect it to
obey it actually does that so let's
select doesn't change those things so
it's just it's just well-behaved and
that's basically just another way of
putting it so that's that's a couple of
examples of functors you've seen me
write code like this so X that selects
and using this you know method call
syntax but we could actually also
rewrite the code in query syntax like
this and often when people see query
syntax there they're sort of used to
thinking about this being something that
involves ienumerable
so this one would you know translate an
ienumerable of int into an i'm new
mobile of string but what if X is not an
ienumerable if X is a lazy of int then Y
is inferred to be a lazy of string and
the same thing goes for tasks so this
this syntax that the she sharp compiler
knows about is enabled whenever you turn
your generically type data container
into a functor you just have to add the
Select method and then that syntax is
available so even though the C sharp
compilers you know we'll see some
examples of this in a moment even though
this is sharp compiler may never have
heard about your generically typed data
container type then you can still enable
this syntax and the reason that this
works is because that language feature
is based on
concept of a functor so whenever you do
something that looks like a functor this
she's sharp compiled it just says hey
that looks like a functor that syntax
will now work so that's basically what a
fun toy is so I'm just the only thing
that I need to do now is just explain to
you what a monad is and that's actually
the easy part you know the function part
was probably the hardest part to
understand so a monad is a function you
can flatten so the only thing we now
need to talk about is what does it mean
for a function to be flattened when it's
a function not already flat so we'll go
back and look at we'll start with
looking at collections for a little
while so here's just a single string so
it's comma separated as you may have
noticed foo come apart but it's one
string and that means we have an
instance method called split on it when
we can call it and then we can ask it to
split on the comma and that gives us an
array of strings all right so that's
fine what if we have an array of
comma-separated strings like this and
we'd say we'd like to separate each of
those strings you know according to the
comma so you might try to do something
like this where you say for each of the
strings inside that array of strings
I'll call split on that string but what
you get if you try to do that is you get
an array of an array of strings so it's
a it's a nested array of strings and
this sometimes this is what you want but
sometimes it's not you just want a
flattened list so what you can do
instead is instead of calling select you
can call a method called select many and
the reason why it's called select many
is because what happens inside of it
produces many values so for each of the
strings you know string that split or is
that split will produce many strings so
you're selecting for each string but
you're selecting many new values and you
want that to flatten as you go and that
works and now you get a flattened list
of strings so this just enable used to
enables you to flatten as you go and the
select many method is basically if you
can implement implement that and and it
works you know intuitively correctly
then this is a monad this this flattens
a list a nested list and that's a monad
it's there's a little bit more to Monat
but this is the most important thing you
need to understand
so we've seen an example of how lists
can be nested and then you can flatten
them as you go so you might wonder is
this also thing that might happen to
other sorts of functions so we've
already established the task of T is a
functor so it might might it sometimes
become nested and that that may be the
case so here I have two tasks of ins and
I'd like to try to add them together but
using this new functor functionality
that I've already have so I might try to
do something like this where I say let's
go X dot select and then I'll have the
integer I inside of that task and then I
can try to sort of add those things
together but since Y is also a task I'll
have to await that so that becomes a
little bit clunky there so I'll end up
with an optic Z which is a task of a
task of an IND which is exactly one of
those nested functors how do we get the
integer out of it by the way well you
can go away to weight set it sort of
like you know when I wrote this example
I said I wonder if we can do this and
then I try to say hey that actually
works that's funny but it's not really
what you'd normally like to do is it's
it's a little bit odd even though it
works it's sort of like yeah maybe not
so what if you had to select many method
you know an extension method for tasks
of T well if you had you can flatten as
you go and then your code would just
look like this so I'm not going to show
you how silic Mini is implemented but
it's fairly easy if you interested you
can google it there's lots of examples
of that but now we have to select many
method more syntax lights up so you
could actually also rewrite the code
like this in query syntax and so not
only does the c-sharp compiler know
about functors it knows about monads as
well it says well you can do those from
from from you know like Cartesian
products of things if you have a select
many method so all of these things this
your Sharp compiler actually already
knows about but to reiterate so far I
understand why some people might get
into this you know idea that you it's
possible to get the value out of our
phone app because for some monads this
is actually possible if you have a lazy
of string you can get the value out of
it if you have a task of string you can
get a value
and this applies to c-sharp it's applies
in other languages as well in in in
f-sharp we have a sink of string you can
get the value out of it even in Haskell
we have these unit containers where you
may have a container with things inside
of it and sometimes you can pull the
these things out of them so there's
definitely a subset of old Munez where
that question makes sense you know how
to get the value out of it but we should
still keep in mind that and the the
function and the monnet that i started
showing you is just the you know the
collections and it doesn't make sense to
ask that question but often people don't
realize that that's a monad so that's
sort of the problem where things really
start to become difficult for people new
to this concept is when you have a
container that may or may not contain a
value so I call those semi containers
because they're sort of like look like
they may contain a single value but
sometimes they don't and I think the one
that most c-sharp developers are
familiar with is no level of T so novel
of T is something where you can you know
have a novel ID like this one and then
often people need to write some some
if-else curve where they say well if
it's not null I know that it's safe to
access ID but value and that gives me an
integer and I can pass that as an
customer ID in this case into my
customer and then I can return that but
now whenever you write code like this
there is also the need for an else
branch because you're returning a new
customer here so whatever you know host
whatever method hosts this little code
snippet here must be some method that
returns a customer so what you do in the
else case well we often see that people
don't really know exactly what to do so
I don't know I'm just going to throw an
exception and and the problem with that
is you know if you put code like this
into a method that that you know
according to its type signature says hey
I'll give you a customer I'll call that
method and then my curve will compile
against your code and I'll say oh that's
great everything works and then I'll try
to run the code in production and then
everything blows up bang because I
didn't realize that there was an
exception like that so if you write code
a lot like this it's sort of like you're
putting a minefield out so that it's
really hard to actually you know walk
through the code base and make sure that
nothing explodes
and often it'll do that it's not a good
way of structuring code so what if we
turn knob of tea into a functor again
the select method is not something that
is available in the in the coal library
but you can add one yourself but there's
one little constraint here you'll notice
that we need to constrain the tea and
the tea result by being a struct you
know a value type and the reason for
that is that knob of tea itself has that
constraint so we can't sort of escape
that constraint but it does enable us to
write code like this where we say we can
transform a novel of int int inaudible
pool because there those are both value
types so that works but then you say
well this is nice because there's no
if-else things going on you know all the
ears if-else stuff is actually captured
inside that select method so that would
give me something then that composes
much better so could I do something
similar with my you know custom ID there
could I write something like this and
unfortunately that's not possible
because it doesn't a pile and the reason
why doesn't compile is because selects
it has to be constrained for for both
the tea and the tea resolves to be a
value type and custom as a reference
type so this doesn't work but if we
really nice if we could do something
like this so couldn't we somehow lift
that type constraint unknowable of tea
well we can't but we can create our own
generically type data container instead
and we'll call it maybe maybe of tea
because that's what you usually call it
it's also known as option of tea so if
you run into that that's the same idea
now in there's plenty of different ways
you can implement this but here's one
way we'll have a flag called has item
and we'll have two constructors so
here's a constructor that doesn't take
in an input argument so that means we
create an empty empty maybe of tea so
that's an empty data container there's
sort of you know corresponds to the case
where the novel of tea is actually no
but then we have another constructor
over Luthor an item and you know sits
that has item flag to true and remembers
what the item is in in another class
field there so at this point we already
have it and generically typed answer
container so the next question is you
know is this a functor obviously it is
because why would I talk about it if
it's not
so we can add a select method it doesn't
have to be an extension method in this
case we can just make it an instance
method on maybe of T and you'll notice
it returns maybe of T result so one way
we could implement that is just looking
at that flag and say if if has item is
true that means the item is available
now remember item has the type T
generically type T and we have this
little function coming in called the
selector that turns any T value into a
TESOL value so we can call the selector
with the item value and that gives us a
T result value and then we can package
that into maybe of T result
so whenever has item is true will map
will be mapping a populated maybe of T
into unpopulated maybe of T result and
if highest item is false we'll just
return you know an empty may P of T
result so we'll translate empty maybe of
T into maybe empty maybe of T result so
that's a structure preserving map it but
it preserves the structure of what it
means to be a maybe object and you can
implement select many as well it's a
little bit different but that just means
that not only is it a function it's also
a monad so what can you do with this
well it turns out to be super composable
and I'll just show you a little example
and then we'll go back to the
async/await example but what you can do
is you can say well we can create a
little helper method called try pass int
that starts with a candidate string and
then it will try to pass it into an
integer and it'll return maybe of int
and you might say well why do you we
need this because we have that in the
base class library already we can do in
to try pass but the problem with inter
try pass is again it's sort of it forces
you to stop whatever it is that you're
doing because now you have to call in to
try pass and you have to set up an out
parameter and you have to check you know
did it return true or false and what do
I do when it returns true and what do I
do when it returns false and you know
that's just a bother so what we're gonna
do here instead of is just gonna say
well if try pass returns true we know
that we have an integer so we'll just
return a populated maybe event with that
integer inside of it and if it's false
we'll just return it an empty one and
you can do the same thing with other
passing things so we can do try path
dates
exactly the same idea so am
now if you imagine that you have a you
have to ride a car rental service and
the first thing you're going to do when
a user starts using your service is
you're calling this method of they're
called collect date and what collect
dates will do is it'll ask the user
please input the date from which you'd
like to rent a car and the user types in
a date and that returns a string and
then you just you know call try past age
with that string and then you get a
maybe update time and the next question
you ask then is say well please input
the number of days you'd like to rent
the car and the user types that in and
that's a string and you pass that string
as an argument to the try pass in method
and you get a maybe event and so on you
can keep on sort of doing you know
collecting data in this way so it met
let's imagine that you do that now what
you really want to do is you want to you
know compose all of that possible data
or hypothetical data into a contract
because the contract has some methods
that will need enable you to calculate
prices and stuff like that so we can do
that with their query syntax here so we
can say from D and M D now D is a
date/time object if it's there and we
can say from I in M I because this is a
monad and I is an integer and then you
can go select new contract and all of
this stuff creates a maybe of contract
and the maybe of contract will be
populated if all the other maybes were
populated and if one of them is is empty
the maybe of contract we all will also
be empty so this is a pretty nice will
understood easy way to do a little bit
of input validation if you need to so so
far so good but then what people often
run into is the this thing where I
disabled the contract has a method
called calculate price and I'd like to
calculate the price because I want to
show the customer or I want to show the
user a quote so you'll often see people
trying to do something like this where
they say let's try to declare a decimal
Q for quote and let's see if the maybe
contract has the item and let's try to
pull the item out of the maybe of
contract and call its calculate price
because I need to call calculate price
this doesn't compile and and this
deliberately doesn't compile because I
designed maybe of T so that has item and
item are not publicly available this is
PI designed because you're not supposed
to do this because again this leads to
brittle code because what do you do if
that if expression returns false what
are you going to which value are you
going to give to Q if if this turns out
not to be the case if has item is false
are you going to throw an exception
again are you gonna create one of those
minefields for me again you're not
supposed to do this this this is not a
good way of structuring code so by
design this is not compatible so we'll
sort of need to reset things a little
bit and say well what else can we do
well you could perform a structure
preserving map so you could just say
let's just call select and inside select
you can call calculate price and that
just transforms your maybe of contract
into maybe of decimal this is completely
safe there's no if-else things you need
to do in order to to make sure that this
works either this lambda expression runs
or it doesn't but in either case nothing
is going to blow up you know
everything's just gonna be fine
so this basically the answers the
question how do I get the value out of
my monad well you don't you inject the
desired behavior into the monad so what
you sort of did here was that I took my
you know calculate price and let's just
put it inside that select method and I
say well if it needs to run it'll run
and if it can't run it'll not run and
everything is safe
so we're never leaving the monad we're
not pulling data out of the moment we're
putting behavior into it instead so
that's that's what you're supposed to do
so that's the you know how do I do X you
don't do X you do set and that will
enable you to do Y that's X Y problem
let's see how much time do I have
okay now I know what you're gonna say
they say well but also my didn't need a
result because I need to put something
on the screen so that the user can
actually see the the the code and you
know a computer may be off decimal on
the screen I need something else okay
now I get it there's a reasonable you
know criticism here let's go back to
collections for a little while
and say well what if you have a
collection of numbers and you say I'm
not gonna put all those numbers on the
screen I need a result well you know if
the result you need is just the sum of
the numbers you can just call that sum
that's a specialized extension method
available and you just get that so you
could do something like that
but what if your requirement is a little
bit different what do you say well for
example you say I'd like to return the
product of all the numbers there's not a
specialized you know product extension
method like the some one here but what
you can't do is there is a general
purpose thing that enables you to
aggregate you know things together and
funny enough that method is called
aggregate so with the aggregate method
what you do is you give it a little
function like a lambda expression up
here that says you know whenever I have
two elements how to combine those into
one and in this case I'm just saying
we'll just multiply them together so
this will work you know without the seed
I'll get back to that seed in a moment
this will work for any populated
collection of numbers now if the
collection is empty which is not right
here I know there's six elements but if
you imagine that array was empty that
lambda expression would not be able to
run and then the aggregate will throw an
exception but if you use that overload
that takes a seed it'll just return the
seed so it just starts by one and incest
you know 1 times minus 3 is minus 3 and
then it goes again and it says minus 3
times 7 is you know minus 21 and so on
but ultimately in this case it's super
boring it just returns 0 because that's
there's a Serie there but the concept of
trying to aggregate you know a variable
number of elements we could sort of take
that idea and translate it back into
maybe but I'm not gonna call the method
aggregate I'm gonna call it match and
there was this reason for that I'll talk
about that a little bit later so it
looks a little bit different but notice
that this is an instance method on maybe
of T that returns a T result and no
matter whether they maybe is empty or
populated we are gonna need a TV solve
that's the guarantee this is the
invariant and basically we just have you
know a single line of code here that
does that we say if has item that's the
flag if that's true we know that item is
available and then we have this little
function
sitting out there that has a weird name
it's called just there's reason for that
sort of an odd name but we can just call
that function just on item item is of
the type T just turns it into a type of
a value of T result and that's what we
need to return so that's good now if the
flag is false we don't have an item but
then we have that nothing value of there
this sort of like corresponds to the
seed in the aggregate method you just
saw and move just return that so no
matter whether we have a populated or an
empty maybe this match method will be
safe to call if you give it the
appropriate input arguments so we'll get
back to that in a little while but now
we'll get back to the or we'll start the
third part of the talk where we'll go
back to this question how to combine
dependency injection with async and a
weight without leaky abstractions
because now we know how to do this or
you may say well I don't but I do so
maybe you don't yet but in ten minutes
you will alright so we we cut we came
from this situation where we were told
that when you do async it has to be a
sink all the way and that is true but
there's a way we can sort of invert how
things work so that our business logic
doesn't have to be asynchronous and the
overall idea is that we move what we do
this is sort of like a catchphrase in
functional programming move impure
operations to the boundary of the system
but what we do here is actually also a
good idea in object-oriented programming
because the idea is that we just take
you know whatever interacts with the
real world and we put that at the
boundary of the system and this is known
as the portion adapters architecture
which is a well-known object oriented
architecture so we're still you know on
familiar ground or we ought to believe
that we are now what's an impure
operation I haven't told you but I'm
just trying to illustrate that by
examples because there's two way an
operation can be impure and we have both
if we have examples of both of those
ways in this try accept method that
belongs to the Maitre D' object here as
I'll just talk about impure operations
by way of example the first one is read
reservations a function should
or normally be pure but one way it can't
it can be impure is if it's non
deterministic so determinism is
something we define by saying well if a
function always returns the same output
for the same input then we say that that
function is deterministic you know two
plus two is always four so that sort of
seems reasonable but when you call a
something like read reservations on a
repository and that's that's going to go
and query a database and it's it's gonna
say well okay whatever is in the
database that's what you've got to get
returned you can now call that method
multiple times and it may give you
different responses even though the
input is the same because the state of
the database is changing in the meantime
and we don't consider the state of the
database to be part of the function so
for that matter we consider such a
function of such an operation to be
impure because it's non-deterministic so
we want to move this to the boundary of
the system and you know what the
boundary of this system is I'll get back
to that but that's basically the post
method now we have another example where
something is impure and that's the
create method and this one is impure for
a different reason and this is impure
because what the create method does it
it creates the reservation in the
repository so it probably adds a row to
the database so doing something like
that is a side-effect and that means
every time you call that method you in
you know you incur a side-effect and
that's another reason why we would
consider things to be impure so both of
these things would I don't want to get
rid of them because this is required
behavior we need this software to behave
in this particular way but I just don't
want to have those method calls sitting
in that try accept method I want to move
them to another part of my system
architecture so we'll start with the
first one but yes this one is the
easiest one to move you'll notice that
this method call always happens there's
no conditions that guards against
whether or not this is possible this
always happens so you might say why does
the try accept method even need to do
this why is it that objects
responsibility it just wants to make a
business decision why does it need to go
and sort of pretend that it's
interacting with the database
couldn't we just make that a requirement
for calling the try/except method that
that data is available and we don't
really care where the data comes from so
we could we can just you know instead of
calling the method will just say well
that data those reservations should be
part of you know the arguments that you
supply in order to call the try/except
method so that's pretty easy
now there's one problem though you know
sometimes things have to get worse
before they get better and the the
problem now is that in order for
everything to compile we'll have to
change the IMH of the interface because
I added that argument to the try/except
method and you know it has to I also
have to add it here to the interface
otherwise it's not going to work so at
this point if you say well you know this
is a leaky abstraction if I ever seen
one if that would be counter to my menu
by doing this I would completely agree
yes this is a leaky abstraction
now I'm only doing you know I'm doing a
series of refactorings and I'm only
started onto them and I'm going to do
more so this is just the first step
towards something better but right now
it looks pretty bad so just trust me
it's gonna be better once we once I'm
done with all the refactoring so we'll
just move on and pretend nothing
happened but if we do something like
this we can go to the boundary of the
system this is where we receive that
incoming JSON document and we could say
well we already have a Maitre D' and
inject it we might as well just inject
the repository as well if we do that we
can call you know read reservations here
so it just moves the method call to that
method instead and then you know I can
pass those reservations as an input
argument to try accept and read the rest
of the code is the same so that wasn't
hard it's just a question of where do
you think that responsibility should lie
and there's a lot of reasons why you
might actually argue that this it's it's
better here you might disagree but we
can always take that discussion you know
the rest of the day if you if you want
to so so that's one of the impure
operations now move to the boundary of
the system so we'll need to go back and
look at the other one I'll just want to
remind you of one thing before we move
on after we've called try/except we
this novel end and you notice just
remember that we're doing a check on
whether it's null and if we decide that
it's not null it's okay to access ID
that value to get the reservation ID out
of it and that's what needs to go into
the 200 okay response kind of make some
changes here so it's just important that
you remember that that's we need to
retain that behavior all right so how do
we move repository create to the bounty
of the system this one is a little bit
harder because there's a condition that
might prevent this from happening this
doesn't happen all the time this only
happens some of the times so if we want
to move repository create to the
boundary of the system we need to
communicate our decision so that you
know the kola of try/except can say well
if we decided to accept the reservation
we should call repository create and if
we decided not to we shouldn't so how do
we communicate our decision to the
caller of this method well we we already
do that because we return this novel of
Ind that's how we've communicated it so
far said well if you get an integer you
have a reservation if you don't get an
integer you don't but the problem with
this is that if I move the respond go
back here if I move if I move repository
create to the boundary of the system you
know that method that is the method that
produces the integer enough if I move
create to another place I will no longer
have an integer so I have this problem
that right now I'm returning novel of
int and that's fine but in general we
have this problem with nullable of T is
that T must be a struct so if I want to
use this type of signal signalling but I
want to return something that is not a
value type I can't use novel of T but I
could use maybe of T so the first thing
I'm going to do is I'm kind of change my
novel of int into a maybe of in just to
make sure that the next step in my
refactorings can work as intended but
the first step is just gonna be this one
so if you just pay attention to the top
line there where you can see the return
values the task of inaudible of int I'm
gonna change that to a task of a maybe
event and the only thing that's that
really changed was just that instead of
returning no I'm returning and
maybe of Ind and in the bottom there
instead of just returning the int and
that gets you know converted into an orb
of ind
i now take the ID that get that I get
from the create method and I wrap that
in a populated maybe event so this still
requires me to change the I'm a 2d
interface and again you know we'll just
pretend that nothing happened here it's
not interesting to look at we'll just
move on and see what happens now the
problem that we're having now is that
the return type of try/except is a maybe
event and as you remember before what we
did is we checked whether it was no or
not and only if we decided that it was
not null we could now go ID dot value so
basically what we did before we try to
get the value out of the monad you know
the novel of T but a very deliberately
design may be so then that's not
possible so how do we deal with this
well this is where that match method
comes in so we'll just kind of call you
know return we're gonna return m dot
match so we want match to produce and a
task of I action results so I'm gonna
use named arguments I'm just gonna say
on the nothing case will return internal
server error that's you know a helper
method that produces one of those I
action results and in the other case in
the just case I have to supply a little
function that receives an integer input
argument and then returns an I action we
solve this output so I was just going to
write the lambda expression that
receives the ID and returns okay with
that ID so I don't have to go like ID
dot value as stuff like that before this
is completely safe if you you know call
the match method with the appropriate
arguments and you're not trying to cheat
it by passing in all or something like
that now this is never gonna throw an
exception well never but you can always
do funny things inside of this but it's
much safer to do it in this way so so
now we're in the position to move
repository create and basically this is
the as you can tell this is the the code
that produces that ID that that integer
so if I remove this method call from
here and move it to somewhere else I no
longer have an ID ID I no longer have an
int so what I'm going to do instead is
I'm going to return a maybe of
reservation so I'm just saying if I
decide not to accept the
servation I'm gonna return a maybe of
reservation that's not populated and
otherwise I'm returning a populated one
and again we'll have to change that I'm
a treaty interface not so interesting
but what we have now is a maybe of
reservation and again I'll remind you
that the the contract that we have with
any HTTP client that calls this behavior
is that in the case where everything
goes well if we return 200 okay we're
supposed to put that integer that
reservation ID into the 200 okay
response body and right now we don't
have a maybe of reservation where we
don't have a maybe of ins we have a
maybe a reservation so how do we turn a
maybe a reservation into a maybe of end
well we have that select method so we
can just call that and we can say let's
call select and inside of select we can
call repository create so this is that
lamp expression is only gonna run if the
maybe of reservation is populated and
it's not gonna run if it's not so
instead of again having to write all
those if-else expressions explicitly you
just rely on the fact that that's what
select does so now we have a maybe event
we're not really we have we actually
have a maybe of a task of an imp because
this is asynchronous but we already
established that task is a monad maybe
as a monad and you can't infer that that
it's you know a combination of those
things will also form a monad it's not
always the case it doesn't have to be
the case but in this case it is so this
is also a monad so we're still in just
monadic territory so everything is good
so we can match on that and this gets a
little bit it looks a little bit awkward
here the code is not the prettiest but
we can clean it up in a little while and
it'll be pretty again but the funny
thing is though that now we have a
compiler warning the compiler will
actually tells us tell us then you know
try accept this async method lacks a
wait operators and it does it says async
up there but there's no await going on
at all nothing is available and you know
are very deliberately aimed after this
because I was really annoyed that my you
know domain logic had to be synchronous
but now it's not so we can just let's
not have it asynchronous let's just turn
it back into be synchronous domain
decisions because that's all it needs to
be and again we'll go and change the
homage of the interface but let's just
skip that and the only change we need to
do here is we just have to remove the
away keyword in front of try/except so
it's just goes like this all right a few
other things we're basically done at
this point but we can go back and look
at the maitre d try/except
implementation and we'll notice another
thing and that is that injected
repository there is not being used so we
might as well just remove that
dependency because that that'll make our
code simpler so what we have now is
close to something called a pure
function it's not quite pure because on
the penultimate line there there we have
a little bit of state mutation going on
but this is something you could refactor
and make it pure if you if you'd like to
but the important part of this state is
that the try/except method here is
completely deterministic you know what
happens here is entirely determined by
the input arguments so you can
completely control you know in which a
branch it'll execute just by making sure
that it gets the right input arguments
so this is interesting if you go and
look at the post method on our
controller here because you might say
why do we even have that I'm a treaty
dependency and you may say well that's
because I want to support unit testing I
want to be able to make sure that the
maitre d has you know deterministic
behavior so that I can you know
reproduce various different test cases
but the implementation that we now have
is already deterministic which means you
can completely control it just by making
sure that it receives the appropriate
input values so I'd say well let's not
have that dependency let's just new a
new up maitre T as we go along because
this will be as unit testable as the
previous thing you can completely
control what's happens here because it's
its deterministic so I've removed the
I'm a 2d dependency so if you do this
consistently all over your codebase you
don't need that interface but just get
rid of it so that's why I said don't
worry about this because in the end it's
not gonna matter now we still have the
Maitre D' object so we still have the
domain logic encapsulated
somewhere but we don't need a you know
an artificial interface to model that
sort of things now the last thing we can
do yep I have a couple of minutes the
last thing we could do is just to clean
up the code a little bit because it
looks a little bit odd particularly I
don't like the match thing with tasks
from resolves and stuff like that so
we'll clean it up a little bit and I
don't have time to explain exactly how
that cleanup works but I have a blog
post where you can see all the details
of that but basically what we have now
we just have a pipeline of things that's
that's executing one after the other and
you notice it starts by saying
repository dot read reservations and
then it just goes start select start
select many and so on so since we're
using selecting select many there must
be a moon at being used here and the
Monad is the task of team o-net or the
asynchronous monad so everything that
needs to be asynchronous is asynchronous
you know we start by calling repository
to read reservations that is an
asynchronous read and then we go and
call Maitre D' to try accept and notice
we've just injected to try accept domain
logic into this asynchronous context and
it doesn't know that it's running in
that asynchronous context it's an
asynchronous method call but it's
running in that context and then you go
in the next line there you go don't
worry about what trove traverses but you
can see repository creates it's there
towards the right there and that again
is an asynchronous right if it ever
happens because it might not actually
happen because there's a maybe involved
as well and then the entire thing is
asynchronous as well it returns a task
of action results so all the stuff that
needs to be asynchronous is still
asynchronous you are still asynchronous
all the way but we've inverted things in
such a way that Maitre D'
you know the domain logic is not
asynchronous doesn't have to be it's
just living inside that context so how
do we combine dependency injection with
async and a weight without leaky
abstractions well we inject the desired
behavior into the async monad and we
sort of knew this already because that's
this is just a specialization on this
more general answer you didn't take the
desired behavior into the monad so
behavior injection not dependency
injection
so um so that's basically it if you were
interested in learning more about this
stuff I have tons of articles on blog
deployed a DK that will walk you through
all of this including all the code that
I've shown you here today and the code
is on github as well I'm out of time so
I'm not going to take questions but I'll
be around at the conference the entire
day and you can just come and talk to me
and ask me questions and I'll be happy
to help you out in any way that I can so
thank you all for coming and I hope you
have a great day today
[Applause]